hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um august 17th
no august 16th today's monday what's
going on why yeah
[Music]
sorry i'm up in the [ __ ] attic of
this house
you know
i'm still on vacation here
enjoying myself i apologize for the echo
there's nothing i could [ __ ] do about
it
but even if there wasn't an echo
wouldn't it wouldn't you complain about
something else
you know wouldn't you be like oh you
know
good podcast but what was up with the
treble
all right first of all
you know
anyway well
what the [ __ ] do you want from me all
right i'm not somebody that has a crew
i don't have a policy
i don't have an ensemble
or an entourage i [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] wherever i can do it so
sometimes it sounds good sometimes it
doesn't
oh man you know what i [ __ ] saw today
really just annoyed the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of me
oh my god it just [ __ ] bugged the
[ __ ] out of me
it bugged the [ __ ] out of me oh did it
bug the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me some
stupid [ __ ] post
you know where mothers are complaining
once again about how they have no
[ __ ] help jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah they're they're unbelievable it
says hey when a kid and then they have a
kid they're like i didn't know it was
work
i'm so tired
[Laughter]
they're just all [ __ ] slapping each
other on the goddamn back about how hard
they work and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you go find that [ __ ] post out there
about fathers
you know i want to see that [ __ ]
goddamn i don't know and if you if you
find it i'm gonna [ __ ] on them too bunch
of [ __ ] babies sitting in a
[ __ ] apartment on a house with a flat
screen tv you got tablets you got more
goddamn [ __ ] to distract your [ __ ]
kid with nowadays and this they're
[ __ ] complaining more than ever
do we listen to the mothers enough
if they're an open dialogue
you know this is what you know the
genius of people that do [ __ ] like that
is they never really make a statement
all they do is just lead these [ __ ]
mouth breathers to it by asking
questions
you know did that song go a little too
far
they just put that idea in some dope's
head they go you know what i think it
did it went too far for me i was raised
methodist or whatever their [ __ ]
dumbass complaint is um
sorry i just woke up to that
i just read that and you know it's one
of those things where you want to chime
in
you want to say something but at the end
of the day like most things
it's like what's what's the upside
where's the upside of this if i actually
[ __ ] chime in there's no [ __ ]
upside i just let him [ __ ] complain
it has to be really difficult
it must be [ __ ]
one of the hardest things in the world
you know
you might want to watch the world news
every once in a while and i think you'd
feel a little bit better about uh you
know feeding your kid froot loops
you know i gotta tell you being an actor
in a movie is one of the most difficult
things ever
i mean you show up and you have these
things to say that somebody else already
wrote so really all you have to do is
just stop on a piece of tape and then
just say what somebody else wrote you
know
and maybe put a pause in there so it
sounds interesting and it makes it look
like you're actually thinking
you have no idea how mentally taxing
that is
um
we as actors
the
the bravery of the way we put our
instrument out there
to be judged
to be criticized
i'm sorry i don't know a third word for
that same thing who gives a [ __ ] um
let's talk about the ocean everybody
paul versi the whole week has been
trying to get me to go swimming in the
[ __ ] ocean
so he does the usual thing about like
you know you actually have a greater
chance of being struck by lightning than
you do
of uh
getting eaten by a shark enjoy the water
all right first of all
who wants to be struck by lightning both
of those things are horrible things
you know that's like you know you have
just this greater chance of getting
unwillingly [ __ ] in the ass as you do
is being lit on fire at a fireworks show
and it's i know that stat isn't true but
i'm just saying both of those things are
horrible
all right
and
i really should have thought this
through more but i'm too far now and i'm
not hitting a race
um
yeah that whole [ __ ] you have a
greater chance of getting struck by
lightning than getting eaten by a shark
is [ __ ] [ __ ] when it comes to me
it isn't because i'm never going to get
struck by lightning because when it's
thundering out i go inside
okay
when i step into the ocean i have now
walked into the room where all the
sharks that ain't at sea world or some
[ __ ] aquarium are at so don't give me
that [ __ ]
i have zero percent chance of being
struck by lightning i don't go outside
when there's lightning
walking into the ocean where the sharks
are is the same thing as with it was
lightning out if i put a [ __ ] i don't
know some sort of metal hat on and just
walked out there so go [ __ ] yourselves
with that not to mention i go out i i
don't go in the ocean i frolic i frolic
along the beach that's where i go
you know
that's where i go takes you back to the
old joke i used to do in my act where
people like you know 90 of shark attacks
actually happen in shallow water these
[ __ ] idiots think you're safer if
you're in deep water it's like dum-dum
that's where the people are it's called
the beach
ninety percent of people that are in the
ocean are at the [ __ ] beach
okay
and then you got the people that like to
scuba dive and swim into caves and get
certified
you know and break records holding their
breath and doing all of that crazy that
that's a whole other that's a whole
other human
all right those people who watched
aquaman too many times and now they want
to go live it
talking to fish
tuda swordfish
um
yeah so i go into the [ __ ] ocean
frolicking with my kids you know having
a good time skipping around
zinc oxide on my cute little button nose
right
and uh all of a sudden i feel something
nibbling at my foot and i look down it's
like this little [ __ ] crab like the
size of my thumb
coming up like hey this is my territory
so i give him a little kick you know was
you know i put on a show i make sure the
santa at the bottom comes up you know
what this guy this [ __ ] thing jumped
up in the air
like jordan
and just had its claws out no it was
like ralph macchio
and a karate kid it just [ __ ] went up
in the air like let's do this i'm just
looking at this little
[ __ ] like i could just crush you and
even you want to fight
you know why that that that you know why
that crap is like that because it knows
where it is
okay it's in the [ __ ] ocean
the thing about the ocean what i love
about the ocean that loves all these
[ __ ]
these these goddamn
sea lion looking people with their rolls
of [ __ ] jelly coming down the [ __ ]
beach
what i love about these people is these
same people wouldn't you know would you
walk into the jungle
barefoot wearing a pair of shorts
if there were bears tigers lions
wherever the [ __ ] you were at
right i guess a bear lives in the forest
i don't know is that like the suburbs of
the jungle
i live in the forest i just got sick of
the jungle too much murder you know too
much crime
just came out here where the air is a
little fresher
less hunters
um
yeah that's what you do when you go into
the ocean you're basically walking into
a jungle that's underwater that has a
bunch of [ __ ] in there that could
[ __ ] kill you including the water
when you walk into the jungle could can
the air kill you
does the air all of a sudden start
moving in a direction that drags you
along and you got to be like okay i
can't breathe right now maybe i'll i
just need to like sort of swim walk
parallel to this until i can [ __ ]
breathe again
um
yeah so i know you guys enjoy the beach
i'm not saying don't enjoy the beach i'm
just saying start coming at me with your
dumb ass [ __ ] stats
all right i know what i'm dealing with
here
jacques cousteau's kid
got killed by a shark
who knew more about the ocean than
jacques cousteau nobody so i'm not
listening to you and you're stupid i
googled chances of hey theory chances of
shark attack and then you're going to
come at me hey hey bill enjoy the ocean
that's what versey says to me enjoy the
ocean as if he just debunked all of my
fears
all of a sudden he's an oceanographer
because he talked to the [ __ ] broad
in his phone
whatever
um having said that my my daughter
wanted to go in the ocean so i put the
floaties on her and i finally said [ __ ]
it i went out there and you know
i had i enjoyed myself you know if
you're into swimming in dirty water i
don't understand what the problem is
well like we got pools
you can see all the way to the bottom
the only chemical in the pool is to help
make the water cleaner as opposed to
whatever the [ __ ] dupont put in the the
water or the raw sewage that people
haven't realized just around the corner
that somebody's dumping in there
um all right bill we get it you don't
like the ocean um i do like the ocean i
also like the jungle i know i'm not a
part of it
actually is that really true
i guess if you go back to caveman days i
am part of the jungle and the forest
wow i just figured it out
i'm a spineless caveman
i'm a caveman that wouldn't have made it
back in the day
um
also i got to tell you i'm into those
[ __ ] kayaks
you know just kind of going around but
you got to make sure you get a bigger
one you get one of the small ones you
don't realize it's just for a kid you
just sink down to the bottom
but uh
i've been watching people cruising
around
just off the coast i mean that looks
better to me
be above the water some shark comes over
it bites you know
do you know you have a greater chance of
being struck by lightning in a kayak
than you do of getting bit by a shark i
would disagree because kayak's made out
of plastic
all right so is the helmet
all right when then the [ __ ] oar is
made out of plastic the handle's made
out of wood
i'm doing all the things i need to do to
avoid lightning
500 people a year get eaten by show
whatever the [ __ ] they said i don't give
a [ __ ]
all right what else can i talk about
here what else can i babble about
babylon about
in this [ __ ] goddamn attic up here
um
did you guys watch that moto gp race
out there in austria
homeland of arnold schwarzenegger brad
binder
he's on the snix it's [ __ ] raining
out everybody else went in and brad
bender wins it
that's how um
um all i think every time i listen to
motogp when it gets exciting is that
spam
from [ __ ] monty python um what a
[ __ ] crazy race
absolutely crazy race
francisco
banya
is that how you say his name was leading
the race also was leading in points
and they're flying around the track
and the whole time they're worried that
it's going to start raining
right and for the most part
it's fabio cuatro this guy francesco
banyai let me know how to say his
[ __ ] name right and mark marquez
and they're going back and forth i lost
count how many times these guys passed
each other
all right which is why i like motogp the
best
and then all of a sudden it starts
[ __ ] raining out these guys are out
there on slicks
doing like [ __ ] you know anywhere
from 150 to 200 miles an hour
and then going into turns when they slow
down to about i don't know like you know
70.
so
there's like five laps to go and all of
a sudden it just starts pouring raining
and now they have to slow down
to like i don't even know what they were
doing i mean i think they were they were
like
i don't know what slowing down a motor
gp is i think on a straightaway they
were they were only going like 80 miles
an hour
and it's pouring rain out with slicks on
and they're racing with each other and
finally with three laps to go
i don't know what the hell somebody put
their hand up they all put their hand up
like [ __ ] it all the leaders we're gonna
go in and we're gonna switch bikes
and get on a bike that has tires that
can deal with the rain right
and so basically everybody went in
everybody followed the leaders because
they were going in [ __ ] it we'll do it
too
but there's only three laps laughs left
so
and um valentino rossi
and a couple other guys decided to stay
out there
so the leaders of the race
go into the pits jump off their bikes
to get on the bike that actually has
tires for the rain that's out there as
brad bender
and valentino rossi these guys they keep
racing and they keep going around and
they build up like a [ __ ]
three-quarter of a lap lead with now two
and a quarter laps to go
then marquez
fabio and [ __ ] fernando get on their
bikes uh joanne meer i think too johan
however you say his name
they jump on their bikes now they start
riding like [ __ ] nine zillion miles
an hour trying to catch these these
[ __ ] guys on their slicks and at one
point they're literally going around
they're going around the turns like
[ __ ] curly like
you know going like 30 miles an hour and
these guys are just barreling down the
[ __ ] track trying to catch him
and the announcer's just losing his mind
you know and it's like fabio's caught up
to valentino garcia
and brad bender ended up winning the
[ __ ] race
winning the race and i think he crossed
the finish line
a motor scooter could have could have
passed it but uh
i really thought it was a crazy strategy
with three laps left
i think the assumption was that everyone
was gonna go in
but um
good on brad binder for winning the race
and uh
having the balls to stay out there
um really exciting race and i'm telling
you f1 people i know f1 is great this
year i'm not saying don't watch f1
because i've been watching a little bit
of it this year it's been very exciting
but like uh
you know motogp i mean yesterday's race
was 28 laps
and that's actually you know on the
higher end they're usually like 23 laps
24 laps it seems
and the [ __ ] is over in like you know a
little over an hour
and there's more passing in one race
than you guys get in like half a [ __ ]
season so i'm really trying to sell you
on that
um
so anyway i've still been out here um
enjoying myself
i did the uh
i did the casino down there in
connecticut foxwoods
on friday night
i had a great time i'm still like the
balance of my act is off right now
you know i'm trashing too much [ __ ] and
i'm not making fun of myself enough so i
just there's a certain feeling i get off
i get when i get off stage and i do that
and i always come upstairs like yeah
it kind of sounded like a [ __ ]
how about being a little more humble a
little more self-deprecating
and then when you go off on something
else it'll hold a little more weight as
opposed to your [ __ ]
you know
i don't know i was a little i was a
little bit in a bad mood because i
[ __ ] go down there
and this guy was driving us down
to the gig
and we get stuck in like [ __ ] just
dead stop traffic
and after like you know 15 minutes of
this [ __ ]
we finally come over the hill
and the driver goes look at that he goes
it's an accident it's not even on this
side of the road everybody's just
slowing down to [ __ ] look at it you
know just like ah these goddamn
rubberneckers and he's like these
goddamn rubberneckers right
and then what was hilarious we pull up
along the accident and our driver does
the same thing
he totally slows down it becomes part of
the problem
and i was with club soda kenny and i'm
just hitting his leg pointing at the guy
going look at him he's doing it the
exact [ __ ] thing he just bitched
about
you know
it's like when your girlfriend's like
you know you need to be nicer to me
you need to appreciate me
and then they they're not nice to you
and they don't appreciate you it was one
of those deals um i'm sure men do it too
to women you know i just haven't dated a
guy yet that's my next move my next
[ __ ] move if this [ __ ] doesn't work
out
i'm just gonna go gay at that point you
know
and just be like all right
what do you you like [ __ ] sports can
we at least [ __ ] do that
um
anyway so i've been eating like a
[ __ ] animal out here but i've also
been going on a lot of walks
and frolicking along the beach so i
think i've been doing all right with the
weight here but uh
you know i had some bar pizza this week
and i also got you in boston you just
got to get a roast beef sandwich
uh
i had a great [ __ ] roast beef
sandwich but i [ __ ] choked i forgot
how to order it i hadn't done in a while
and they had this giant menu
the lady was all like uh what do you
want and i was like uh oh
sandwich roast beef roast roast beef
sandwich
and she like looks at me and looks at
the menu she's like yeah which one do
you want
oh my god
sub
and then i regained my footing how big
is this small
and i was like okay that sounded good
and i just [ __ ] up and i was like just
lettuce tomato mayo i forgot to order
cheese and i didn't say to toast the bun
or heat it up so i was just like [ __ ]
it was still delicious though
still delicious i told you guys last
week i went to a clam chat shack i got
chinese food
i had some bar pizza i've been trying
some different places out here along the
[ __ ] coast
um
and uh
i don't know i i really
kind of love being back here and one of
my favorite things that sense of being
back here is my mlb package is not
working
because the game is blacked out
and the place i'm staying doesn't have
nessen
so i've just been listening to the game
on the radio the w-e-e-i network
and uh although i missed most of the
[ __ ]
baltimore series because i was working
or hanging out with friends and [ __ ] and
uh of course they won every game
so they've won six
of their last 14 games right six and
eight in their last 14. i think i saw
all eight games
that they uh
that they lost
and i missed all six games where they
won
so at this point i'm calling jinx i
didn't see all eight games i probably
saw six of the games that they lost
um
so i'm trying to stay away from them
because we got the [ __ ] new york
yankees coming to town they're a couple
games back but they've played a few
games
less than us uh chris sale is back which
is huge
for us so we'll see we'll see what
happens
you know you got to have sale in the
lineup because then that that's the guy
that stops you know from the losing
streak that's how i look at it oh is
that how it works bill oh i think it
does
i think it does you got a problem with
that
um
all right
you know just i just feel like as a
mother i just like nobody's helping me
what a way to start your day
whining on social media you know why
don't you be a man and do it on a
podcast
all right
[Laughter]
oh god i'm so full of [ __ ] all right
candid everybody let's do a little bit
of advertising here
um
as i've been on dick's sporting goods
looking up kayaks
uh i'm into it man
it's like being on a magic carpet right
above like you could fly on a magic
carpet above the jungle
and be like look at that lion down there
you know you can't get me up here that's
not true you're on my nuts i'm on the
surface
you ever see that [ __ ] at the zoo when
they build like a uh
one of those enclosures
for like a leopard or a lion and they
think that it can't get out
and then one day they realize like oh
it can get out it was just never mad
enough
to want to get out and somebody goes to
the zoo and they start [ __ ] with the
thing
and you know once a cat a big cat just
decides
you know what
i believe i have to kill you there is
nothing anybody can do unless they're
sitting there with a giant [ __ ] gun
and they're a good shot
do you ever hear that story those kids
were taunting that [ __ ]
tiger was it in san francisco
i don't know what they were saying i
don't know if they were [ __ ]
you know
if if the tiger was woke and he didn't
like their politics let's see
kids
taught how do you spell todd
you don't spell it like that kids taught
tiger
san francisco
tiger that mauled three teens at san
francisco
did the tiger get a little teardrop
tattoo before they killed it the tiger
that mauled three teens at san francisco
zoo appears to have been provoked
this was
10 years ago a female siberian tiger
killed in a hail of police gunfighter
after fatally mauling a man
at the san francisco zoo on christmas
day 2007
likely was provoked into leaping and
clawing out of its enclosure a federal
investigator said in the documents
obtained by the associated press first
of all can we just stop for a second
and just realize the story that those
police officers have
for the rest of their lives you know
when they retire i was a police officer
oh were you and somebody tries to tell
some crazy story
i had this perp you know he
rolled up on him four in the morning
stealing a car stereo that's a [ __ ]
80s thing to do but whatever
you know got into a gun battle oh yeah
is that what you did
i took my glock out and i killed a
[ __ ] tiger
after it mauled three people at the zoo
all right
the tiger named tatiana killed 17 year
old i'm not going to say the person's
name and injured his friends
uh
brothers
oh two brothers that were with them
leaving claw marts etched
in the asphalt and claw frag fragments
in the bushes of its pen claw marks were
also discovered near the top of the
enclosure which was lower than federal
safety standards dictate showing that
the big cat was able to get enough
leverage to pull itself out
i bet that tiger was working out at
night when none of the [ __ ]
zookeepers were looking
doing [ __ ] pull-ups in the human flag
it appears the tiger was able to jump
from the bottom of the dry moat to the
top of the wall and gain enough pressure
over the top to pull herself out over
the moat wall
with my knowledge of tiger behavior i
cannot imagine a tiger trying to jump
out of its enclosure unless it was
provoked
yeah i remember reading about this story
and this [ __ ] tiger got out of this
thing and it was all these innocent
people who didn't do [ __ ] to the tiger
and they were like oh my god oh wife you
know
screaming bloody murder and the tiger
ran by all of them
trying to find this specific kid like
this had nothing to do with any use
all right
he came back like [ __ ]
like the gunslinger when he walks into
the saloon and everybody knows there's
going to be a gunfight and all the
regular people that churn butter and
just [ __ ] plow the fields behind
oxens all stand up slowly and back out
of the [ __ ] bar
until it's just the badass loner and the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that did him wrong
that's what happened at that zoo except
instead of clint eastwood
or charles bronson
it was a tiger
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that they had to kill the tiger they
should have been yelling at those kids
well see that that's why you don't [ __ ]
with the tiger
all right sorry
let's get to the advertising here shall
we all right candid everybody
there's a specialist for just about
everything right when your car breaks
down you go to a mechanic when there's a
problem with your shower you call a
plumber when there's a pandemic
sorry so when you want to use a pandemic
you talk to your friend who tells you
some [ __ ] he read on the internet about
lightning and sharks so when you want to
get uh so when you want to get your
uneven crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist
they're the specialists and that's what
sets candid the invisible comfortable
and removable aligners above the rest
while poorly reviewed or insanely priced
clear aligner companies use general
dentists
you know that's like uh you know i got a
[ __ ] problem with my ass here and you
just go to you go to somebody who just
gives physicals
it's like i need a i need an ass doctor
here well poorly reviewed uh the general
dungeon candidate only works with
orthodontists with candid
the same orthodontist who created your
plan is with you from st to finish
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing your treatment is prescribed and
closely monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
you can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you
or do everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home you know
when they said expert in tooth movement
the first person i thought of was mike
tyson
the average candid treatment is just six
months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces and with your aligner
treatment you'll get candids teeth
whitening for free i mean come on people
you're talking about fixing your teeth
here
you know whitening them up
you walk into a bar
you see whatever you're into you flash
that beautiful smile
tell a couple of jokes and you're in
there
unless you're near the gorilla enclosure
never show your teeth because gorillas
take that as aggression
you want to give them the old man gummy
smile um candid can help you get the
straighter brighter smile you've always
wanted right now you can save seven and
five dollars uh on your candid starter
kit when you get started from home or
you can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you go to candidco.com
and use the code bur that's candid
charlie
oscar.com code bird take advantage of
this limited time offer to save 75
dollars on your starter kit
candidco.com
code burr
oh look who it is everybody endo cheeto
you know the right outfit can bring a
special something out of all of us
and with indochino creating your best
look yet
could be more affordable than you think
talk about any special occasion that's
that have been postponed over the past
year or events that are coming up soon
that you're looking forward to oh
uh i went to a wedding a few weeks ago
we had to work around all of that you
know and i wore a suit and i felt
special indochino it may have been a
while since the last time you had an
excuse to dress up but whatever that
next chance is make the absolute most of
it with indochito indochino i know china
offers completely custom fitted suit
shirts casual wear and and more at
surprisingly affordable prices
every piece has made your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail detail choose everything from
your suit
about your suit from the fabric lapel
monogram and statement linings you can
create a suit that fits you and your
style perfectly the best part
of waking up
is indochino in your closet indochinos
start
at just 3.99 with all customizations
included indochino is open at selected
at select nordstrom stores giving you
even more ways to get a great fitting
personalized clothes and personalized
clothing find your nearest location at
indochino.com right now you can get 50
off any purchase of 3.99
or more by using code burr at checkout
that's 50 off of purchase of 3.99
at i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burr india november
delta oscar charlie hotel indian
november oscar.com
promo code bird that's for the pilots
who want to wear a nice suit
next time they fly
instead of dressing like the guy from
the love boat gavin mccloud
rest in peace man i'll tell you that guy
played such a great
gangster
and scumbag and nobody knows that
because he everybody remembers remembers
him from murray
and uh on mary tyler moore and captain
stubbing
on the love boat but you gotta check him
out and peter gunn
he plays a gangster and just is really
really just comes off as sinister and
then i saw an old episode of uh the
untouchables
and uh he plays uh you know a guy
running like a gambling site
not a gambling site
a gambling operation
you know back when you couldn't hide
behind a website and all of a sudden you
know he gets some guy who double crosses
him and all of that [ __ ]
you know
a lot of people don't know this before
gavin mccloud got on mary tyler moore if
you saw him acting he had a really good
chance of getting rubbed out every time
um all right stamps.com everybody this
summer
is showing welcoming signs of a more
normal life ahead finally you can get
back to enjoying life's little pleasures
like smiling at your neighbors seeing a
movie and going to the post office
smiling at your neighbor good lord
what a great person
they think you are huh do i smile at my
neighbors i do
you're smiling at your neighbor it kind
of comes off a little creepy
saying hello to your neighbor hey how's
it going oh yeah yeah you washed your
car looks great
you know just sitting there
smiling at them
to the point they start talking like uh
hey there
see you behind the bushes hi
sorry
okay
some parts of normal life aren't so
great but with stamps.com you can skip
to the post office you go sorry
you can skip trips to the post office
and save on postage uh you've heard me
talk about stamps.com they've been
sponsoring the show for over nine years
now and if you haven't tried it the hell
are you waiting for
you can wait a whole decade go by
uh they make it easy for small
businesses to mail and ship without
needing to take a trip to the post
office they offer deals you can't get
anywhere else like up to 40 percent off
usps and up to 66 percent off ups
shipping rates
[ __ ] i think it's dusty in here
um and with their switch and save
feature you can quickly compare carriers
to find the best rates every time stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead
you silly goose there's no risk and with
promo code burr you can get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
now long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burp b-u-r-r
that's
stamps.com promo code burke
um all right dear professor
oh we got all the questions here
everybody's giving me [ __ ]
saying that that [ __ ] guy that said
you can't tell a joke at school was
trolling me and it's just like well
that's one of the most easiest things to
do
you know i don't read
you know
i hang out by myself i'm very gullible
and if that makes you feel like a bigger
person if that's the way you get your
fun
all right french runner
bill did you see this french [ __ ] at the
olympics
i love french [ __ ]
i'm a part french [ __ ]
he's a marathon runner knocked over all
the water on the table so no one after
him could get a sip oh wow
wow
i did not see that
that is amazing
um sorry i was so enamored watching the
guy wow he knocked him all down and then
just grabbed the
oh they're in water bottles
that is amazing hey what's up buddy
am i being too loud well i came up to
the top of the house so i wouldn't be
loud
am i saying the bad words
[Music]
well maybe go down okay i'm sorry i'm
almost done here can you close the door
i thought i'd close the door
there's that conversation she just
walked out of me um
that's hilarious
and you know what's great about that is
there'll now be a new rule saying you
can't do that and it'll be named after
him
um
well you know
to quote the tampa bay lightning fancy
dude it's legal
there's nothing against it unless the
patriots do it then it's [ __ ]
cheating that's one of those things if
somebody with the patriots logo did that
there would be a massive suspension but
if anybody else does it it's just like
it's a little gamesmanship
um i think it's [ __ ] hilarious
because there is nothing to say that you
can't [ __ ] do that
um and i would love to hear his excuse i
was so tired i was hallucinating i just
reached out and it took me a second
to register that i was touching water
bottles specifically 24 of them in a row
but on the 25th and last one i realized
i was actually touching a water bottle
and it was an illusion at which point my
hand closed and i was able to pick it up
i apologize my heart goes out to the
other racers
um
i think that's [ __ ] hilarious all
right wendy's story slander
hello billy dave's double tits
greetings from dallas while i was
driving into work i was listening to
your podcast we were talking about your
guilty outing to wendy oh wendy's this
is who you're talking about i thought
you said i trashed some woman named
wendy wendy
uh you planted the idea into my head
of what going to wendy's so that while i
worked tirelessly through my morning as
an electrical engineer
first of all can we all just stop and
just thank
this person
for how brave they are and what a
warrior they are
that
they're out there making sure people
have their lights on
and their cable tv so that they can
watch the next episode of down under
i fantasize about the unhealthy mess of
a burger that wendy's could cook up to
clog my arteries come lunchtime i
ditched the salad that i packed and
drove to the wendy's down the road oh
man i did this to you
you should have had the salad
sorry the first thing i noted that was
off with your story was that wendy's
uh that the wendy's that i went to had
coke products on their menu pleasant
surprise to me
um
well the one i went to had a pepsi
however i didn't want any of your
potential listeners to deter wendy's
from any profits due to the expectation
of pepsi products granted that this
might be a taxis wendy's verse
california wendy's thing i took a
picture of the menu
okay so do i to match you with the thing
i mean whatever it was it tasted like
[ __ ]
so when it tastes like [ __ ] i think
that's a pepsi
i might have been wrong who knows
who knows on the subject of the menu you
also complained
was i complaining or trying to make you
laugh no i resent i resent that word
okay you know what i'm not accepting
that
all right i was complaining you're right
that it was hard to find the plain
burger meals
on the contrary the classic birders were
literally the number one me
go [ __ ] yourself i'm taking a picture of
it
great now my kid's gonna yell at me you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] self-centered
you're just as [ __ ] self-centered as
i am you went to one man wendy's in the
middle of texas and then you immediately
assume that this is what all [ __ ]
wendy's like
believe people who went to wendy's
i am a survivor and why are you not
listening to my [ __ ] story
you're not validating it
um on the contrary the classic burgers
were literally the number one meal on
the menu well on mine if you wanted the
classic ones
it was just written in like
they had a picture of all their new ones
and out of mind it was just it was just
written
like it would just say single
cheeseburger double cheeseburger
triple cheeseburger and it was just all
in plain black font that was a subset of
a picture of a different burger like the
uh
what the the ostentatious whatever the
[ __ ] they called the dumb ass burger
the son of the the son of the
[ __ ] burger whatever they call
it um on the contrary the classic
burgers were literally the number one
meal on the menu i'm sure this is just
the senile old bird talking and
complaining how things aren't how they
used to be and yelling your kids to stay
off his lawn
uh no it isn't you just went to a
different wendy's
okay you live in texas backward ass
texas
all right you guys are behind the
[ __ ] curb i live in [ __ ] la
let me ask you this did it say how much
all the calories were because that's
what mine said
listen buddy it's a corporation
okay and in each area they're gonna find
different things sell due to the
demographic
due to the level of education that's out
there in the public schools
all right you go out to la everybody's
on the [ __ ] keto this diet this beach
diet and that beach died but they know
you're still gonna go to wendy's so what
they do is they go oh this is uh this is
bourbon batter they try to make it seem
more [ __ ] healthy
all right so i think that that's what's
going on here
before you start questioning
my mental stability
i know i can't read but i i you know i
can [ __ ] read a fast food menu
all right i'm gonna take a picture of
that buddy all right because you know
what's funny is you have i don't see a
picture of yours
um menu
at least here there's a giant question
mark is that where the picture was and
it didn't download i don't know
okay here we go
on the subject and menu also complain
okay wait
another important note listen to this
guy tyler he's made an important note if
you had gotten a medium meal instead of
a large fat ass meal you would have
gotten your drink in a cup and a paper
cup instead of the gigantic
dolphin murdering plastic cup
oh is that how it works
all right
was there like nobody in line behind you
in your moment of gluttonous weakness
you [ __ ] over some fish which is going
to swim into your giant-sized wendy's
plastic cup and die when the cup ends up
in the ocean
um
yeah way more than one fish it's gonna
be out there for a thousand years
uh now that i ate this double meal i
feel like death and feel that i need to
run 20 miles to make up for the supposed
1 500 calories that were in this meal oh
so they had the calories listed out
there
um all right well you know something you
[ __ ]
fast food eating [ __ ]
i understand that a lot of that was the
grease the reason why you came at me and
i also understand you're breaking my
balls but dude i'm telling you
let me just let me i gotta look it up
now
there we go
our fast
food chain
menus
different
in
it says in florida in the philippines in
hawaii all right what do i do here
different
how do you spell difference different
states
fast food chains adapt to local
[ __ ] tastes
there you go buddy all right dum-dum
well i'm out here in texas i can tell
you right now they got the single they
got the double they got the triple it's
the first [ __ ] one yeah that's cause
you guys still think the [ __ ] world
is flat they know you're not [ __ ]
progressing out there so they go with
their old [ __ ] menu i'm reading the
new testament out here that's got
lettuce wrapped horseshit and giant
[ __ ] pepsis all right
i'll meet you in [ __ ] arizona we can
look at the wendy's out there
all right cancel culture of the past
hey billy redbeard by the way that
information came from cnn.com so you
know
who knows
all right they're as reliable as the fox
guys there i said it to both of them so
now they can [ __ ] shut up cancel
culture of the past hey billy redbeard
long time listener first time writer
uh so i was listening to an episode of
the podcast where the guest starts
talking about cancer culture of the 60s
in regards to mccarthyism and the red
scare my dumb ass thought that was in
the 50s
i guess the guy saw twilight zone
episode and addressed it guy concludes
that if cancer culture was here 60 years
ago it's never going away
do people not realize that this [ __ ] has
always been here
um
yeah people realize that there's always
been people trying to end people's
career
but in the past it was always people
with power
you know they achieved something they
got to a certain level and then they
abused their power
you know back in the day the head of a
studio could end some nobody's [ __ ]
career
in a heartbeat
right but now the tape i don't think
ever in history somebody that never
accomplished anything nobody's ever
heard of
can end the career of a
multi-millionaire
who has a [ __ ] house with an infinity
pool i mean that you gotta admit that's
new right
you know what i mean and i know that
kings have been taken out of power but
like bloodshed happened
if you're going to compare like [ __ ]
storming a castle
by the surfs or whatever during medieval
times
to moving your thumbs and hitting send
on twitter
like that's the same thing
i don't know i think it's pretty amazing
type of thing and as always what you see
is that rich people are not evil
they're just regular people with money
that's all it is that whole [ __ ]
thing where they try to make oh you know
you know white people are evil the
blue-eyed devil and all that it's like
no white people are you with unchecked
power
when people have unchecked power
regardless all of this [ __ ] women ran
the world no them too everybody
everybody with unchecked power
for the most part
you know it's very rare that you get a
jimmy carter
very [ __ ] rare
somebody that actually has empathy and
is a caring human being and i love to
this day that people are still like yeah
but the guy wasn't a good president
it's like that's because all of those
evil sociopaths wouldn't work with the
guy
how many presidents
the guys he's out
you know they all just [ __ ] buy
mansions
and go to [ __ ] martha's vineyard this
guy's is like in his 90s he's still
built building houses for homeless
people
winning like nobel peace prizes after he
was in the white house i mean the
proof's in the pudding this very a very
rare
person
unfortunately and if we just i think i
believe that if you know male female
gayle
gayle gay straight whatever if you get
more people like that in power
and have them all working with each
other i think we'd be in a lot better
position as opposed to just you know
looking at ties and the colors of them
or whatever
um anyway do people not realize that
this [ __ ] has always been here
just in recent memory everything from
mccarthyism talking targeting imaginary
legions of communists to anita bryant
trying to get every homosexual working
in the public sector fired
yes but she's in a position of power
right
to the satanic panic of the 80s trying
to ban
uh dungeon and dragons
yes but all this is the difference
though
this is the difference with all of that
is those all were organizations that had
power
i mean the pmrc was al gore's wife
tipper gore so he at that point was like
a [ __ ] i don't know what congressman
or a senator they had power
they had a microphone they had a
platform
nowadays it can just be like you know
somebody that cleans a hotel room
and if the person in staying in the
penthouse is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
get it on video that guy loses him or
her loses their career that this is
a whole new phenomenon
and then you combine you com
bind that with
the abuse of that power which then when
the trial is now on the internet
where there's there's no rules of libel
or slander and you can really just say
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
um which used to be
just
the world of
powerful people with money that they
could you know
they could set the narrative now all
regular people can do it
um no i think this is like a new thing
and i don't think that like what was
happening with lenny bruce
is the same thing as what's happening to
say comedians today where it then goes
into their private life
you know used you know you could always
get in trouble for [ __ ] that you said on
stage absolutely but it's just like you
know he came into the hooters
and you know i just felt he was toxic
and blah blah but then all of a sudden
you lose your agent i know this is like
a whole
like
i don't know
that's like oh you know
there's always been music
sebastian but you know uh you know we're
not sebastian parker whatever the
[ __ ] real guy classical music and
trying to compare that to uh
you know
people have always gone to concerts and
been a little crazy people used to go to
classical things and then comparing that
to people going to like raves and dying
and [ __ ] like [ __ ] is you know can
progress that was a bad example [ __ ]
that the music one i'm just saying
um
i don't think that we've been like
in a world where uh
made-up non-events
about individuals
who are telling [ __ ] jokes and strip
malls can be the lead stories
on late night news that is allegedly
news that isn't news
you know my whole time growing up i mean
comedians
i i never saw george carlin as a lead
story
like i mean when richard pryor like lit
himself on fire and ran down the [ __ ]
street yeah
[Laughter]
but you know when he [ __ ] was
shooting up his cars i didn't hear him i
mean i guess i wasn't watching the news
back then but i i just don't think it's
uh
i understand what you're saying if you
you're basically saying that since
um
the beginning of time people have tried
to take out people
without a doubt they have they
absolutely have but like um
this
this thing i don't know i just i think
it is is morphed in i guess the musical
type of thing it's just like
you know jazz was big and now rock and
roll is big you're like yeah yeah you
know it's all music it's all the same
thing it's like okay yeah i'll go with
you on that level but there's definitely
a uh
i find it disturbing that people now
do what like
these 24-hour news networks do
where
they'll put a headline on a video that's
misleading and they'll also
edit it
in a way where it's just like you
literally are like your own news network
right now you are trying to control
the narrative
of these stories and the fact that
you know
every single person for the most part
has a cell phone with a camera
and uh
and video abilities and then they can
upload whatever they shot
you know and and they decide when they
can begin it when they can end it
i just no there's never been a time like
this
there hasn't been
um
so i i
i disagree with what you're saying um i
would say there's always been people
trying to destroy people
but with the technology that is
available now
for anybody to do it i think this is a
new level how about that how about we
agree that there's a new level
um anyways there was a congressional
hearing where rock stars and rappers had
to go before government committees like
some trial of socrates [ __ ] to prove
that they weren't corrupting the
american youth with their damn deviled
music
this [ __ ] never leaves yeah but that's
the government
it's always been there it always will be
here it doesn't ebb and flow it just
changes targets no
no
sometimes its target is far enough away
from me personally that we can pretend
we don't see it happening stop saying we
this is your point stop acting like
everybody agrees with you um i i 100
disagree with you that this canceled
culture thing is not some new
thing
you know it's it it's
been ramped up like i said back in the
day you had to get into a position of
power and you had to know enough people
to control the narrative
of of of what you wanted to have happen
you had to pay people off you had to do
all of that [ __ ]
um
now like somebody you know you know in
some ways it's good because you know if
someone's actually doing something
and they are super powerful it gives
people who aren't powerful a voice that
aspect of it is good
but
with that power comes the abuse of it
and um you know
a lot of the [ __ ] that you see out there
so uh
i disagree with what i agree that that
people have always been trying to take
out people but back in the day for the
most part it was it was powerful people
doing it and
everybody walking down the street didn't
have the ability to create their own
news story
with their own thoughts in their own
video and their own like clips
um i mean look at that little [ __ ]
click bait and all of that [ __ ] that
they have out there that just regular
regular people do that now
because they know what plays and they
know what they have to say
to get people to click on it so they can
get click on it so they can get eyeballs
so they get people to advertise like
there's never been a time in history
where every person walking down the
street is thinking like they're running
their own tv network
and then you combine that with how most
people cannot handle positions of power
and you have this [ __ ] show that is
going on right now
um which i think
that it's as the similar thing from back
then was it's always just been a
distraction from what's really going on
what you really should be say paying
attention to
um
you know who actually has the money who
really is running things what direction
are we really going in how politicians
are all kind of paid off they're
deliberately underpaid so they owe
people favors
that whole [ __ ] horse [ __ ] where you
can attach all those things to bills
so horrific things get attached to
things that people want and then we
don't have we don't get a right to vote
on a lot of those all of that [ __ ]
uh i don't know i disagree with you i
respect your opinion there you go please
don't cancel me all right angels of
fenway
hey saggy tits
[Laughter]
i just listened to the latest episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast and since
you got sentimental about being back in
boston and sitting by the ocean i
thought i'd send you a song
recommendation
you probably know this but in case you
don't check out james taylor's angels of
fenway i don't know this would be
interesting to hear what you think i
heard you making fun of james taylor a
few times
i made fun i make fun dude there's so
much [ __ ] i make fun of that i actually
like okay
you know i like the carpenters but you
know
rainy days and mondays always get me
down i'm gonna make fun of that song but
i also and when i hear it i go back to
riding in the back of a station wagon in
the 70s so there's part of me that likes
it i like james taylor
um i also like making fun of him i also
like that blacktop movie that he made
whatever the [ __ ] it was called i forget
um aren't so anyway so you open up a
diet fan so open up a diet fan
sit down by the ocean and give it a
listen love your comedy and podcast
please keep doing what you're doing all
the best from germany
that's pretty random somebody from
germany would know all of that stuff
maybe it's a military guy there you mean
one of the troops
one of the heroes
uh see let's listen to james taylor
angels of fenway i can already tell you
right now i'm already getting
uncomfortable just with the name of it
but that has to do with me and my
childhood more
more than james taylor angels
of fenway
oh
boy
oh boy here we go
let's see how far into the song i can
get
wait a minute
did he write this for the red
[Music]
okay okay okay that is the red sox
version of like those 911 songs
that all those country guys wrote
you know what i mean uncle sam's gonna
put a boot in your ass
now i'm not saying that the person who
wrote that song's heart wasn't in the
right place but to you know
to just sort of capitalize on that and i
know you donated the money to the
[ __ ] ambulance drivers and the
firefighters and all that [ __ ] but you
also got your big mug put right in the
middle of the [ __ ] footage
and uh country music stars responding to
the horrors that we saw last week this
is uh [ __ ]
whatever
you know [ __ ] colt mcranch face
his [ __ ]
terrorism ban we don't like it
american flag yeah
sing it with me
put down your fried noodles
um
sorry
you know that tragedy it happened to all
of us and everybody has a right
to react
you can be silent
you can use your voice you can be
creative
it's okay to be angry
it's okay to
cry never hear people say stuff like
that i just think to them like
how [ __ ] up by you
that's the question i want to ask on a
scale of one to ten emotionally how
[ __ ] up
are you
that you feel
that you need to take care of the world
and your ego is telling you that you
have the ability to do it
what happened to you
how much were you beaten down as a child
that your ego now tells you like i need
to speak on this
i need to say something
and when i say something i'm going to
say something that's already been said
and i'll just combine it
be brave
be courageous
be original not really
just say the things that you say
thoughts and prayers with the families
during this difficult time
people if you need help know that
there's help out there i love people
have this literally sound bites to say
when somebody kills themselves when
there's a tragedy
you know it's like you didn't even take
enough time to write something original
a stitch in time saves nine
hold your children a little closer
tonight
it's just like
you going with stock lines
what what about this tragedy said to you
that it wasn't unique enough or painful
enough for you to come up with something
original
ah
i'm being a douche this week all right
everybody
um that is the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll check in on you on
thursday i'm gonna [ __ ] uh
hang out
and uh watch the [ __ ] yankees and red
sox
they got a double header tomorrow
and um and then he got wednesday oh and
i got a big special guest
for the uh thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
that in show business
is known as a effort
oh jesus that's why i said effort wait
it's known as a teaser
all right that's the podcast everybody
all right
stay safe
help each other
pour some ice over your head
do the things that you need to do
that you'd want to be done to others if
they were you while you were
being brave and
you know looking up the sky and just
being present okay i'll see you